nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
en tout 3 28e j med i want your browser
c'était la danse aussi tu m'avais vue
d'enlever des liens tu es là bien tu
veux tu que je sois si les pâtes tout en
continuant à danser avec moi d'un petit
os 8 it is
profitons-en pendant que le grand yaka
prend sa douche repas se fait plaisir de
voir un peu la lumière
alain on dans will orchestre que leurs
oeuvres mais les musiciens tu veux t'en
si sa musique
hu à la musique la musique tu crois que
c'est indispensable que question on ans
peut-être sans musique chez les lions
mais pas chez des souris
nous sommes des artistes nous a menti
varois je mate apprendre à danser comme
vous êtes maman
[Musique]
la musique adoucit les morts vous voilà
kial main
bah ouais alors peintre ou sans les
musiciens dans ma poche octobre au ca
est abrasif store jaulin rapportait le
de ma tournée triomphale un aux états
unis
en guise de 120 gr
[Musique]
en revoit importe d'où l'étonnement et
le peintre père
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrêtez arrêtez les invectives boucherie
des musiciens club dedans écoute c'est
une plaisanterie mais le crottin qu'un
autre du la musique et veut voir les
musiciens pendant nos deux clients n'a
pas voilà allez ma femme avant les
commissions vipérine il rentre dans la
boutique plus grands lanka 90 auctoriale
ça fait partie du grand yaka trouve là
tu te feras tenter un coup de bateaux
venant tant que bien appartient garde le
barbu ce temps et arrête la musique
titus pour sur les musiciens y en a pas
grand lui a pas mais je te la musique
écoute ma foi grand encadrement tonga
nous remet mois d'où l'intérêt pour ce
cas est-ce que tu est un des visiteurs
ça dépend encore yaka mais je l'entends
moi c'est une musique de mes oreilles de
l'inter et on vous connaît sa gangue à
quatre cantons des bandes moment c'est
terrible de bourg de nous mêmes c'est g
qui disent non croyants cas mais tester
boules de coton dans vos oreilles et
vous l'entendre tous les bons moments
que je suis des cours donnés mosca et
ses superbes jeux d'antan plus riez
vient d'entrer dans la liste le grand
gala n'entendent plus rieur vive la
musique
et après après frais de nos déboires
[Applaudissements]